[Music]
star talk
uh an explainer
explainer we do this sometimes jack
hey hey i need you there when we get
when we do explainers but this one i
know a little bit about we're going to
talk about the james webb space
telescope i know a little bit about it
but not enough to fill a whole explainer
on it
so we reached in
to nasa headquarters
and we found we found the chief
scientist and there he was and he's on
star talk right here right now jim green
jim it's a delight to have you we go way
back thanks for being on star talk
neil my great pleasure and chuck good to
see you again definitely good to see you
jim jim green you you you you come to us
as a planetary scientist from way back
and your chief scientist at nasa and
you're retiring next year
will we go what will we do
what are we going to do oh my gosh
and wait wait you're retiring right when
the james webb space telescope deploys
this is a little suspicious if you ask
me
[Laughter]
not not really but after 42 years
you know it's uh it's time
uh you know to step into retirement but
you know i'd like to uh continue to work
with nasa i have several papers i need
to finish
i want to work with nasa on gravity
assist and uh you know uh do these
things that i like to do
so you've got a gravity assist podcast
that's the best title ever for a podcast
i just want to thank you put in my vote
for that and
you just published a book a 50-year
review of planetary exploration at nasa
and it just came out just
congratulations on all of the above the
podcast the book the retirement the
career and now we got to pick your brain
about james webb space telescope yeah i
got 100 questions and i just want to
hear it from the horse's mouth sorry to
call you a horse in this but
a mouth i do have
all right everyone is thinking of this
as like the replacement for hubble so
could you just
amend that
thought for us all yeah
you know
when we go into space we have the
wonderful opportunity to look in
different wavelengths wavelengths of
light that don't make it to the surface
of the earth now hubble actually looked
at the visible many of those wavelengths
all those wavelengths make it to the
surface of the earth but
not into the infrared and that's why we
needed a new telescope
and that's what the james webb space
telescope does it it really hones in on
a brand new wavelength
regime that we haven't done much with
so uh what intrigues me is when i first
learned of the james webb and how it's
tuned for the infrared
i being fundamentally a a large-scale
structure guy of the universe i was very
excited to recognize that it will be
able to see the formation of galaxies in
the early universe in a band of light
that is red shifted into its
into its zone i mean right it's it's
like the universe is as
it's like
put it here universe and then we got you
right right yeah well it's a it's a time
machine yeah so basically yeah the
further it looks the further those
objects are away
the further back in time we see them
and their light was
started out as
ultraviolet or maybe even some x-rays
and by the time it reaches us through
the expanding universe it's landing in
our lap as infrared and you got the damn
telescope to find that but then to learn
that it's not only finding the farthest
reaches of the universe
infrared can actually
peer into
gas clouds so tell us about that
ah well that's a really important uh
aspect of it because it allows us to
look at the birth of stars and their
associated planets
and that really is uh exciting to see
and these are just right in front of our
noses right so yeah and that's what
intrigues me it's the farthest reaches
of the universe and things that are
happening right in our backyard our
cosmic backyard right within our own
galaxy
where do you decide to point it first
ooh good question oh well you know uh uh
scientists um uh propose right there's a
cage match there's the octagon
with the chainsaw
don't forget the chainsaws
you got to have that seriously you got
to put that in but that's got to be your
retirement legacy you know the first
light on a telescope is whoever wins the
cage match among the astronomers you got
to do that
yeah right indeed well you know
much of that early part of the program
has been worked out
but we also have some time about a
hundred hours that have been set aside
to look at the solar system
now this is really an exciting thing
because i was at nasa headquarters as
head of planetary science
uh from 2006 on and in about 2007 we
went through a review on what jwst could
do and in that review i said at the end
of it well aren't we going to use it to
look at objects in the solar system
because our sun heats them up and they
glow in the infrared and we can look at
aurora infrared aurora on planets all
kinds of things were coming to my mind
and i was told
no this is an astronomy telescope and we
can't track things and so um ellen stern
the aaa at the head at the time turns
he's mr pluto he's mr mr please allen
pluto stern that's his middle name
[Laughter]
don't get anything started don't derail
this conversation
so so alan turned to me and said um well
what what do you think we ought to do
about it i said let's
let's take a second and see
if uh what needs to happen for jwst to
track objects in the solar system and so
it was early enough in the development
the project went away and they came back
a couple months later and said we got
great news it's just a software uh set
of mods that we can make and we can
track things from mars on out
wow wow so
there's an important point you're making
there because when we see the distant
universe
nothing is moving at any rate that
matters to
you just sit on that spot on the sky but
everything in the solar system is moving
yeah and of course
we need time to collect those photons
even though we have a huge collecting
area we want to see out into the kuiper
belt you know and that they'll emit in
uh infrared but they're so far away from
the sun that it will still be dim
because
of which pluto is a prominent member
yes yes one of the archetype members of
uh or you mean escapee
i don't know
oh dear oh what have i done
you know uh some of them haven't escaped
you've got triton which is probably a a
a
kuiper belt object you know in orbit
around neptune so
so what what happened is the project
said it just cost money now's the
perfect time to do it add the money and
we can complete the software and track
uh track objects and alan turned to me
and said green you got the money and i
said i'm going to do whatever i can to
get you the money and indeed that's
planetary's investment in this
spectacular telescope is is getting the
software that enables the telescope to
track
objects from mars on out in the solar
system that's that's a beautiful thing
and and uh remind us where this thing is
getting planted it's not just in earth
orbit like hubble
that's right it's in a very special
place
and uh this particular place is behind
the earth in in what we would call the
earth's magneto tail okay
and it's called uh l2 it's a little it's
an anatomical part you know
yes
that's right
a magnetotax it sounds like a new x-man
magnetotail
so so that's that's how you remember to
pronounce magnetosphere correctly is
think of magneto and then put a sphere
on the end of it good good nice all
right so this is on the other side of
the moon right
no it's directly behind the earth in
line from the earth to the sun
oh
interesting l2 is behind us and and it's
a unique place because what's happening
is in that location it's really orbiting
the sun
but because it's behind the earth it
would move slower around the sun than
the earth does
but here's where the earth comes in the
gravity for from the earth
pulls it along
and so not only the sun's gravity but
the earth's gravity keeps it in a nice
position we call l2 which is like
920 million miles away from the earth so
this has nothing to do with the moon
moon keeps doing its orbit around the
earth right like like nothing's
happening while this spacecraft is still
out there so if you're an l2
can we get there to service it in case
we need to
i know that's a big topic a lot of
people ask that and the answer is it
never was planned to be serviced so
uh-huh
so i'm going to be able to do that at
this stage at this stage okay so in
principle though l2 if it's going to be
a happening place to plunk future space
telescopes and and whatever else might
live there because lagrangian points
those are those are fun points to hang
out in um
i can imagine i'm making this up just
spitballing here nasa has a has a has a
has a handyman mission
it's the handyman
uh uh uh
vehicle that goes out there and you and
you collect all the the spacecraft that
need um all the space telescopes that
need repair and then it comes back
how about
that well that's a good thought
uh but
that's not nasa's thought
our prime mission is indeed uh for a
nominal five-year mission but it has
fuel
to station keep meaning stay in l2 you
know
uh for about 10 years
wow yeah i'm thinking of a handyman
mission okay i'll work on that jim we'll
call it nasa's aaa
oh you need you got a flat you need you
need a jump
[Laughter]
well you may need fuel that's probably
what you'll need i i can't i can't
believe i locked myself out of my
satellite
wait so jim jim i got one last question
because we're running short on time
is there a mode the telescope can go in
that is because what i'd always loved
even telling the public about that we do
as scientists is
of course
you design an instrument for what you
intend to find
all right that's how you know what the
parameters are and what the specs should
be
but is there a mode where it's just
looking for nothing
like a serendipity mode
so in case something shows up that
nobody ordered nobody was looking for
and we end up scratching our head when
it shows up like every other telescope
in new york city
well like hubble you know which decided
okay we've got some spare time let's
just stare in an area and then found the
you know fabulous array of galaxies that
it did there'll probably be some time
when we will
you know look in a particular area and
then just turn it on and see what we
find but at the moment it's really well
subscribed as we would say you know we
have a hundred hours uh uh open to the
planetary scientists to make a variety
of measurements of solar system objects
that data will come in and be available
to all the other planetary scientists
and and then many of the astronomers
uh will have already accepted proposals
and they'll be uh you know following
following that schedule that they've
created
but that won't really kick in until six
months after launch
okay
and but the point with that famous photo
the hubble deep field we're just stared
at nothing for a long time it became one
of the most famous images it ever took
that was the director of the hubble
space telescope institute
saying do this and i don't care what
anyone says because i'm the director and
i have directors discretionary time is
there someone in jbj because it's not
gonna be you because you're retiring is
there somebody's gonna say
let's just do this don't judge me until
after is there someone who has that
power
perhaps
um
you know
another cage match
[Laughter]
but hubble was up for many many years
before that all right and therefore
therefore they they felt they
they had opportunity to then reach
outside the normal set of things that
they'd be doing to discover something
new and important perhaps
and so that's why i say initially it's
really well subscribed we've got so many
things we know we need to uh make those
observations to make those discoveries
and so that's first on the list
all right jim it's been great to have
you on here we've got to end it there
but we look forward to the launch we
look forward to the successful
deployment uh that's going to be a nail
biter uh deploying something that's
never existed before
who knows
if somebody forgot to you know unlatch
something before it was loaded right you
know that's then someone needs some
explaining to do on that uh but anyhow
we look forward to this and
congratulations on a a marvelous career
uh i've known you ever since i've known
nasa so
i feel like uh you and nasa have become
one
yeah thank you that was very kind of you
to say
and your gravity says podcast check it
out and of course of 50 years of
planetary exploration just published by
nasa and so you can uh check that out as
well if you want to sort of eavesdrop on
on what was going on
so a chuck always good to have you man
always a pleasure excellent neil
degrasse tyson here as always keep
looking up
[Music]